franchement pour les plus jeunes
vraiment c'est vraiment passionnant
c'est vrai j'ai connu un directeur
artistique une grande maison de disques
qui brandissait la libye de la création
pour satisfaire sa libido
tu comprends si on couche pas ensemble
je ne pourrais pas travailler avec toi
ouais si je te vois comme ça et que je
peux pas te toucher je peux pas je peux
pas à coucher avec toi ça va être
impossible donc ça ouais non mais
franchement romane ça on a l'impression
que ça fait d'être dans des mauvais
films auraient syrie où les mecs et les
filles autour de la table où même les
garçons est ce que ça vous est déjà
arrivé d'avoir des trucs un peu chelou
comme ça ou des trucs un ben oui oui oui
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
oui moi ça m'est déjà arrivé
effectivement et des fois c'est terrible
de se dire que pour parents sortir abîmé
c'est plus simple de dire oui que de
dire non pour être sûr de s'en sortir
bien après il ya des bons payeurs
effectivement et les pressions de
personnes qui se sentent obligés et j'ai
eu la chance d'avoir cette liberté mais
je comprends qu'il ya des personnes qui
sont coincés là dedans quoi ces
terribles télé il ya quelques années
j'étais au malheureusement au festival
de cannes et moi j'essaie un exemple
assez affligeant c'est qu'on m'a on m'a
emmené chez un bijoutier on m'a dit bah
voilà donc on m'a mis un bijou autour du
cou normalement généralement c'est pour
monter les marches
et là il m'a dit écoute tu peux garder
mais ce soir il faut que tu prennes soin
de moi oh la la
et du coup bah du coup j'ai paniqué je
me suis dit ou est-ce que j'ai mis les
pieds j'ai vraiment eu très très peur
pour moi et du coup je n'ai pas su quoi
répondre j'ai vite enlevé le truc et je
suis parti en courant rejoindre mes
copines et je leur ai dit bon bah là y'a
un truc qui craint les filles faut qu'on
parte quoi ouais c'est terrible